in today's eight on your side women
after 50 are entering some of their most
productive years even post-pandemic
this according to life coach holly
kaplan who calls it the midlife
anti-crisis
she says a lot of women have been in the
workforce in corporate america for 25
plus years
and now they're ready to do their own
thing and women are feeling more
empowered to do so
the pandemic offered women the chance to
reinvent themselves and realign
themselves with what's right for them
here's one example of what one of her
clients did
one of my clients is a chef and she had
planned on opening her
first restaurant last february and then
you and i know what happened then
everything just shut down
so she was kind of freaked out about it
and sat still and she was like what am i
going to do now
so she looked at what she loved to do
which is cooking and being a chef and
she decided to do
a home food delivery service so now
she's doing that and she's also doing
private dinners for special occasions
so she took advantage of
the situation instead of just just
sitting in silence and being afraid
because of what just happened with code
but she turned it into
her full-time hustle holly says find a
great support system as many women are
going
through the exact same thing you are and
brainstorm write down all the things
you've ever wanted to do regardless of
how silly they may seem
eliminate from there and look at what
you can do with a career that's
sustainable
and of course if you need coaching you
can certainly reach out to her on her
website at holly kaplan